It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans start at $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正飞速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢喧闹无比，我的连接依然稳定。此外，无限流量套餐起价为每月 35 美元。这真是一个不会长久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。需加收税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. and do you go along to get along or say yes when you really want to say no? We've all done it, agreed to a volunteer position that we didn't really have the time for, or held our tongue at the holiday dinner table to avoid a family fight, or kept quiet at work when speaking up could have helped a colleague avoid a mistake. Today we're going to talk about the psychology of speaking up and saying no. Why is that so hard to do?
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负荷使用期间不会遭遇数据流量降速。你会为了合群而选择顺从，还是在真正想说“不”的时候说“好”呢？我们都做过这种事，比如答应一个自己其实没时间去做的志愿者岗位，或者在节日晚宴上闭口不言以避免家庭争吵，或者在工作时保持沉默，而当时直言本可以帮同事避免一个错误。今天我们要讨论的是直言不讳和拒绝的心理学。为什么这件事这么难做到？
What does it mean to defy, to comply, to compromise? comply or to consent. And how can you strengthen your resolve and ability to say no when the situation calls for it? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Sunita Sa. Dr. Saw is an associate professor at Cornell University's SC Johnson School of Management, where she studies ethics, authority, compliance and defiance, including questions such as why we comply with bad advice and how disclosure policies can backfire. Her research has been published in many academic journals and covered by
反叛、顺从、妥协意味着什么？顺从还是同意。当情况需要时，你又该如何增强自己的决心和说“不”的能力？欢迎收听《心理学热议》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是苏妮塔·萨（Sunita Sah）博士。萨博士是康奈尔大学（Cornell University）SC 约翰逊商学院（SC Johnson School of Management）的副教授，她在该领域研究道德、权威、顺从与反叛，包括诸如我们为什么会顺从糟糕的建议以及披露政策如何会适得其反等问题。她的研究已发表在许多学术期刊上，并被
media outlets, including the New York Times, the Harvard Business Review and Scientific American. Her new book is called Defy, the power of no in a world that demands yes. Dr. Saw, thank you for joining me today. It's wonderful to be here. Thank you, Kim. The Oxford English Dictionary defines defiance as to challenge the power of another person boldly and openly. But in your book, you offer an alternative definition. Can you tell us what that is and why you felt defiance needed a new definition? Absolutely. So I've been fascinated by what that single word defy means for a very long time.
各大媒体报道，包括《纽约时报》、《哈佛商业评论》和《科学美国人》。她的新书名为《反叛：在要求说“好的”世界中“不”的力量》（Defy: The Power of No in a World That Demands Yes）。萨博士，非常感谢您今天能来到节目中。很高兴能来到这里。谢谢你，金。牛津英语辞典将“反叛”定义为“大胆且公开地挑战另一个人的权力”。但在您的书中，您提出了一个替代的定义。您能告诉我们那是什么定义，以及为什么您觉得反叛需要一个新的定义吗？当然。事实上，我长期以来一直对“反叛（defy）”这个单一词汇的含义着迷。
So as a child, I was known for being an obedient daughter and a student. and I remember asking my dad at one point, what does my name mean? And he told me, in Sanskrit, Sinita means good. And I mostly lived up to that. So I did what I was told. I did my homework as expected, went to school on time. I even had my hair cut the way my parents insisted. And these were the messages I received, you know, to be good, which means to be polite, to obey, to listen, not question authority. And many of the words, get these messages from a young age. And we start equating compliance with being good and defiance with being bad. But when I looked into it, and I've been studying this now for a very long time,
作为一个孩子，我因做个听话的女儿和学生而闻名。我记得有一次问我爸爸，我的名字是什么意思？他告诉我，在梵语中，Sinita 的意思是“好”。我基本上也一直是这样生活的。所以我做被要求做的事。按预期完成作业，按时去学校。甚至连发型都是按照父母坚持的那样去剪的。而我接收到的这些信息就是，你知道的，要听话，这意味着要礼貌、服从、听话、不质疑权威。许多人从很小的时候就接收到这些信息。我们开始将顺从等同于好，将反叛等同于坏。但当我深入研究时——而且我研究这个已经很长时间了——
I saw that there were some problems with that in being so compliant. So, for example, one survey found that nine out of 10 healthcare workers, most of them nurses, did not feel comfortable speaking up when they saw a colleague making an error. And it's the same across industries. So in another survey of over 1,700 crew members of commercial airlines, about half of them felt uncomfortable saying something when they saw a mistake. So these could be life and death consequences. We want these people to be speaking up when they see an error or a mistake. And it made me start to wonder, is it sometimes bad to be so good? what do we sacrifice by being so compliant? And what I discovered now that I've been looking at this for years,
我发现过于顺从存在一些问题。例如，一项调查发现，十分之九的医护人员（其中大多数是护士）在看到同事犯错时，觉得不敢直言不讳。其他行业也是如此。在对 1,700 多名商业航空公司机组人员的另一项调查中，大约有一半人在看到错误时觉得不敢出言制止。这些可能会带来生死攸关的后果。我们希望这些人看到错误或失误时能够直言不讳。这让我开始怀疑，表现得这么好有时是不是一件坏事？我们因为过于顺从而牺牲了什么？而现在我研究了多年，我所发现的是，
even if it's not life and death situations, when we don't speak up, when we see something wrong, it can be quite draining and have an effect on us. And I often felt a lot of tension between that aspect of doing what was expected of me and doing what I thought that was right. And that inspired so much of my research. And what I discovered that I think is crucial and really changed how I think is that we've misunderstood what it means to defy. So I'm not one to usually disagree with the Oxford English Dictionary.
即使不是生死攸关的情况，当我们看到不对劲的事情却选择保持沉默时，这也相当消耗精力，并会对我们产生影响。我经常在履行对我的期望这一方面和我认为正确的事情之间感受到很大的张力。这激发了我的许多研究。而我发现的、我认为至关重要且真正改变了我的思维方式的一点是，我们误解了反叛的真正含义。所以我通常不是那种会反驳《牛津英语辞典》的人。
After all, I grew up in the UK. But I think that definition of defiance that you described is too narrow and doesn't honour our agency. And so my definition of defiance is that to defy means to act in accordance with your values when there is pressure to do otherwise. So it takes defiance and transforms it into a positive pro-social force for society. Because if you think about it, Kim, all our individual acts of consent and dissent every day add up to the society that we live in. And so it affects our lives, our workplaces, our communities. And that's why I'm so passionate about it and think that we need to understand what defiance really means and the power behind it. Now, as long as we're talking about language, let me ask you the difference between compliance and consent.
毕竟，我在英国长大。但我认为你刚才描述的那种反叛的定义过于狭隘，并没有尊重我们的自主性。因此，我对反叛的定义是：反叛意味着在面临相反的压力时，按照自己的价值观行事。因此，它将反叛转化为对社会的一种积极的、亲社会的正向力量。因为如果你仔细想想，金，我们每天所有的个体的顺从与异议行为，汇聚成了我们生活的社会。因此，它影响着我们的生活、我们的工作场所、我们的社区。这就是为什么我对这个课题充满热情，并认为我们需要理解反叛的真正含义及其背后的力量。既然我们在谈论语言，请允许我问你，顺从和同意有什么区别？
Absolutely. Well, the two are often conflated, but they are actually quite different. So to comply with something just means to go along with something. And it's usually externally driven. Somebody is asking you to do something or there's expectations in your organization or in society. and is to go along and do comply with that expectation. Consent is not compliance. Consent is a thoroughly considered authorization that is an active expression of our deeply held values. So why do I say that?
当然。嗯，这两个词经常被混为一谈，但它们实际上非常不同。因此，顺从某事仅仅意味着随大流。而且它通常是由外部驱动的。有人要求你做某事，或者你的组织或社会中存在某种期望。而顺从就是随波逐流并顺从这种期望。同意不等同于顺从。同意是一种经过深思熟虑的授权，是我们深层价值观的积极表达。我为什么这么说呢？
Well, I worked as a physician before I became a organizational psychologist, and what I do in my research is take informed consent, the definition of informed consent from medicine and apply it to other decisions that we make in our lives. So for informed consent, we need five elements. And these are, so first of all, capacity. We need to have the mental capacity to make a decision. So physicians assess patients for capacity. Is this patient too ill, are they under the influence of any drugs or alcohol?
嗯，在成为组织心理学家之前，我曾是一名医生，我在研究中所做的工作，是将医学中“知情同意”的定义应用到我们生活中做出的其他决策中。因此，对于知情同意，我们需要五个要素。它们是：首先，民事行为能力（capacity）。我们需要具备做出决定的精神能力。因此，医生会评估患者的决策能力。这个病人病得太重了吗？他们是否受到任何药物或酒精的影响？
So first of all, hopefully we have the capacity to make a decision. And then next, we need knowledge. so we need information on the decision that we're about to make. But it's not just knowledge, it's not just receiving the information, it's understanding it, which is the third element. What are the risks? What are the benefits? What are the alternatives?
所以首先，希望我们具备做出决定的能力。接下来，我们需要知识（knowledge）。我们需要关于即将做出的决策的信息。但不仅仅是知识，不仅仅是接收信息，而是理解它，这是第三个要素。风险是什么？收益是什么？替代方案是什么？
And to really understand that. Then the fourth one is this freedom to say no. Because if we don't have the freedom to say no, it's not really consent. It's simply compliance. And if those four elements are there, then you can engage in the fifth element, which is your authorization. So if you want to say yes with all those elements, you have the capacity, the knowledge, the understanding, the freedom to say no, then that's your informed consent. If you want to say no, that's your informed refusal.
并且要真正理解这一点。然后第四个要素是说“不”的自由。因为如果我们没有说“不”的自由，那就不是真正的同意。这仅仅是顺从。如果具备了这四个要素，那么你就可以参与第五个要素，也就是你的授权（authorization）。因此，如果你在具备所有这些要素的情况下想要说“好”——你具备能力、知识、理解力、说“不”的自由——那么这就是你的知情同意。如果你想说“不”，那就是你的知情拒绝。
Why do most people find it so hard to say no even when we know we should, whether that's agreeing to an obligation we don't want or staying quiet when we see someone behaving unethically? In those moments, what is it that holds us back from speaking up? Well, we often actively resist defiance, and there's a number of reasons I've found for this, but one key reason is that we feel this enormous pressure to go along with other people, this social pressure. And I've seen this time and time again in my research experiment after experiment. So let me describe this type of pressure that I'm talking about.
为什么大多数人发现说“不”如此困难，即使我们知道自己应该这么做，无论是答应一个我们并不想要的义务，还是在看到某人表现出不道德行为时保持沉默？在这些时刻，是什么阻碍了我们直言不讳？嗯，我们经常积极地抵制反叛，我发现这有许多原因，但其中一个关键原因是，我们感到了顺从他人的巨大压力，这种社会压力。我在我的研究中一次又一次地看到了这一点，实验接连不断。所以让我来描述一下我所说的这种压力。
And it could range from small-stakes situations to much larger ones. So when I was working as a junior doctor, my first job, I received an invitation to meet with a financial advisor for free. And I remember that meeting really well because it was in the posh meeting room at work. So as posh as you can get on the National Health Service, it was a room I didn't even know existed. It had a carpet. There was a couch.
它的范围可以从低风险的小事情到大得多的情况。因此，当我作为一名初级医生工作、担任我的第一份工作时，我收到了一份与财务顾问免费会面的邀请。我清楚地记得那次会议，因为它是在工作场所豪华的会议室里举行的。作为国民医疗服务体系（NHS）里能办到的最豪华的房间，那是一个我甚至不知道存在的房间。它铺着地毯。还有一张沙发。
I was like, how come I've never discovered this before? So I went in after a long night on call and I sort sank down on the sofa and Dan, who was the advisor when he walked in, he was tall, he was Hansen, big smile, smart suit. And he greeted me warmly and he spent an hour talking with me. He asked many questions, mostly about my finances. He built up this amazing report. And after about an hour, he asked me whether he could write a report. he would send it in a week and he recommended that I invest in a couple of funds. All of this was for free.
当时我值完漫长的一夜班后走进去，整个人陷在沙发里。顾问丹（Dan）走进来时，他身材高大、英俊、带着灿烂的笑容、穿着笔挺的西装。他热情地迎接了我，花了一个小时和我交谈。他问了很多问题，大部分是关于我的财务状况。他建立了一种非常棒的融洽关系。大约一个小时后，他问我是否可以写一份报告。他会在一周内发给我，并建议我投资几只基金。所有这些都是免费的。
So I was impressed and I had to ask him, what's in it for you? And he said, well, there's no such thing as a free lunch. And he would receive a commission if I invested in the funds that he was recommending. So he disclosed this conflict of interest. And what was key for me is that that disclosure did change the dynamics of the situation. So I did feel less trust in the advice. which is arguably the intended purpose of that disclosure. But at the same time, I now felt more pressure to go along with his advice
所以我印象深刻，不得不问他：这对你有什么好处？他说，天下没有免费的午餐。如果我投资了他推荐的基金，他将获得佣金。因此，他披露了这一利益冲突。对我和最关键的是，这种披露确实改变了情况的动态。因此，我对这些建议的信任确实减少了。可以说这也是这种披露的预期目的。但与此同时，我却感到了更大的压力，想要顺从他的建议，
because I didn't want to signal that distrust to him. I didn't want him to think that this disclosure had now corrupted the lovely rapport that had been built up. And I started to feel really uncomfortable and I just then just wanted to sign and say, okay, fine, I'll invest in these ones. And what's happening there is the psychological process of insinuation anxiety. So this is a distinct type of anxiety that arises when we worry about our noncompliance with another person's wishes, is going to be interpreted as a signal of distressed and insinuates that the person is not whom they appear to be or should be,
因为我不想向他显露这种不信任。我不想让他认为这种披露已经破坏了我们之间建立的极好的融洽关系。我开始感到非常不舒服，只想签个字说：好吧，没问题，我投资这些就行了。而这里发生的是“暗示焦虑”（insinuation anxiety）的心理过程。这是一种独特类型的焦虑，当我们担心自己对他人意愿的不顺从将被解释为不信任的信号时就会产生，这暗示着这个人并非他们表面上看起来的那样，或者不应该是那样，
that they're not trustworthy or competent or have integrity or benevolence. And it's an aversive emotional state. We become so concerned with offending the other person, we comply with them. Even in one-off situations I've found with strangers, we have a huge amount of compliance because we don't want to insinuate that our advisors, our co-workers, our friends are not trustworthy. So I'm sure we can imagine a situation where a boss is asking you to do something, everybody's going along with it, but you don't think it's right. But it's just too difficult to tell them that they're wrong, right?
暗示他们不值得信任、没有能力、缺乏正直或仁慈。这是一种厌恶性的情绪状态。我们变得如此担心冒犯对方，以至于我们选择顺从他们。我发现，即使在与陌生人的一锤子买卖中，我们也会表现出极高的顺从度，因为我们不想暗示我们的顾问、我们的同事、我们的朋友是不值得信任的。所以，我确信我们可以想象这样一种情景：老板要求你做某事，每个人都随大流，但你认为这并不对。然而，要告诉他们他们错了实在是太难了，对吧？
or that we're at the hairdresser and we're sitting there and they're cutting away, cutting away, and you're thinking, no, that's not what I wanted. And it's just really hard to sort of tell them, no, this is not good. We normally just say, yes, thank you, and tip and walk out and feel dreadful. And so it happens in those everyday interactions. But what my research has shown me is that it's also in larger stake situations. So in medical scenarios, when your doctor disclosed, a conflict of interest, people feel more pressure, more insinuation anxiety to go along with it.
或者我们在美发沙龙里，坐在那里任由理发师剪啊剪，而你在想：不，这不是我想要的。要开口告诉他们“不，这不好”真的很难。我们通常只会说：“好的，谢谢”，然后给小费走人，内心感觉糟糕透顶。因此，这种情况发生在那些日常互动中。但我的研究向我表明，它也发生在风险更高的情境中。因此，在医疗场景中，当你的医生披露利益冲突时，人们会感到更大的压力，产生更多的暗示焦虑，从而选择顺从。
So even though trust decreases, insinuation anxiety increases, and it depends on which force is greater as to whether they will take the advice or not and go along with that. So it's really important to know what that feeling is, this insinuation anxiety, and name it. Because once we name it, we know what we're dealing with and we can understand it. So what are some steps a person can take to overcome the pressure to comply? Are there things you can do in the short term and in the long term? And is this a kind of muscle you can train so it gets stronger? I absolutely believe that.
因此，尽管信任度下降了，但暗示焦虑却上升了，而人们最终是会采纳建议还是拒绝并顺从，取决于哪种力量更强大。因此，了解这种感觉——这种暗示焦虑——并将其命名是非常重要的。因为一旦我们给它命名了，我们就知道我们在应对什么，并且可以理解它。那么，一个人可以采取哪些步骤来克服顺从的压力呢？你在短期和长期内可以做些事情吗？这是一种你可以训练从而变得更强大的肌肉吗？我绝对相信这一点。
So in the short term, I'll tell you what happened to me when Dan asked me to invest in those funds is when things were starting to just get that little bit too uncomfortable. and the silence was a little bit too much, I was thankfully saved by my beeper going off. And that was not planned, but I managed to leave the room. And he was like, no worries, I'll send you everything as planned. But when he did, I had time to think about it and think about my extremely limited disposable income. And, well, actually, I don't want to invest in these particular funds. And it was much easier for me to make that decision away from debt. So this is what I call the power of the pause.
所以在短期内，我告诉你当丹让我投资那些基金时发生了什么，当事情开始变得有点太不舒服时，
If you can just pause rather than agreeing in the moment or on the spot, and especially if you can get some physical distance, that really helps decrease that signal of distrust. Because if this is social pressure, what we want to do is reduce that social interaction as much as we can. So if we can make the decision in private, if we have an opportunity to change our mind, in all my experiments I show that compliance goes down,
如果能够当场不急于答应，而是暂停一下，特别是如果你能拉开一些身体上的距离，那真的有助于减少这种不信任的信号。因为如果这是社会压力，我们想要做的就是尽可能减少这种社会互动。因此，如果我们能在私下做出决定，如果我们有机会改变主意，我在所有的实验中都表明，顺从度会下降，
a huge amount. But making the decision in front of the other person is what leads us to comply a lot of the time and shows us that our public behavior is not in alignment with our private preferences. So we really need to be aware of that. But what's even better than just sort of thinking about the power of the pause in the moment is to really train ourselves for defiance. Because if you're like me and you had a master class in compliance growing up, you don't actually have the neural pathways to know how to defy it, and we need to train them. Because we know that training makes a big effect, right? Our brains have what we call neuroplasticity, so the neural pathways can change. If we're wired to comply, we need to change that wiring. So how can we do that?
降幅非常巨大。但在另一个人面前做出决定，往往会导致我们顺从，并表明我们在公开场合的行为与私下的偏好并不一致。因此我们真的需要对此保持警惕。但比在当下考虑暂停的力量更好的，是真正为反叛训练自己。因为如果你像我一样，在成长过程中接受过顺从的大师级教育，你实际上并不具备如何反叛的神经通路，我们需要训练它们。因为我们知道训练会产生巨大的效果，对吧？我们的大脑具有所谓的神经可塑性（neuroplasticity），所以神经通路是可以改变的。如果我们天生倾向于顺从，我们需要改变这种连线。那么我们该怎么做呢？
Well, we can start anticipating situations that require defiance. So the next time I see a financial advisor, for example, I will know if they disclose a conflict of interest. If anyone discloses a conflict of interest, I will have some familiarity with that. So I find that surprise really disables defiance. It makes us freeze. But if we can anticipate something, we can then start visualizing it and role-playing or scripting it out and practicing it. And it's that practice that changes the neural pathways. In terms of anticipating, I always get asked, how do we know, right? How do we know what we need to defy?
嗯，我们可以开始预测需要反叛的情境。例如，下次我再遇到财务顾问时，我就会知道如果他们披露利益冲突的话会发生什么。如果任何人披露利益冲突，我都会对此有一定程度的熟悉。所以我发现突如其来的惊奇实际上会剥夺反叛的能力。它让我们呆住。但如果我们能预测到某事，我们就可以开始将其可视化，进行角色扮演或编写剧本并加以练习。正是这种练习改变了神经通路。在预测方面，我总是被问到：我们怎么知道呢，对吧？我们怎么知道什么时候需要反叛？
Well, a lot of situations in which defiance is called for are actually quite predictable. So, for example, I know in a particular faculty meeting, there will be one colleague that will always say something inappropriate. You just know that this is going to happen. Perhaps you're in a job and you know, in this particular job, I might be asked to look the other way. I might be asked to do something unethical and you need to be prepared for that. So that anticipation is really important. We can't anticipate everything, but we can anticipate a lot of things. And we know the situations that we've
嗯，许多需要反叛的情境实际上是相当可预测的。例如，我知道在某次特定的教职工会议上，总会有一个同事说一些不恰当的话。你就是知道这件事会发生。也许你正做着一份工作，而你知道在这项特定工作中，我可能会被要求视而不见。我可能会被要求做一些不道德的事情，你需要为此做好准备。因此这种预测非常重要。我们无法预测所有事情，但我们可以预测很多事情。并且我们知道那些我们曾经
struggled with in the past. And we can think about those and practice what we wish we had said. And why is that so important? Well, there's this famous quote that's often attributed to Bruce Lee, but was actually a Greek poet, that I think really shows us the importance of practice and training. And that quote is, under duress, we don't rise to the level of our expectations. We fall to the level of our training. And so that's why it's so important to start practicing for defiance and learning the skill long before the moment of crisis. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill for burner gas grill on special buy for only $199.
挣扎过的情境。我们可以思考这些情境，并练习我们当时希望说出口的话。为什么这如此重要？嗯，有一句著名的名言经常被归功于李小龙，但实际上出自一位希腊诗人，我认为它真正向我们展示了练习和训练的重要性。那句话是：在压力之下，我们不会提升到我们期望的高度，而是会跌落到我们训练的水平。这就是为什么在危机时刻到来很久之前，就开始为反叛进行练习并学习这项技能是如此重要。你的夏天从全国家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Nextgrill 四 burner 燃气烤炉来开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。
And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See homedipo.com slash price match for details. I have to ask, though, why are we still here? of such psychological studies as the Stanford Prison Experiment, Stanley Milgram's research, that we're still obeying authority. That work is decades old, but we still been to authority when we know we shouldn't. So do you think your book and your work is going to penetrate more
还可以用汉普顿湾（Hampton Bay）韦斯特格罗夫（West Grove）七件套户外餐桌椅套装享受整个季度的聚会，仅售 499 美元。今年阵亡将士纪念日，在全国家得宝享受超低价格保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，不适用于某些情况。详情请访问 homedepot.com/pricematch。我不得不问，为什么我们仍然会受到类似斯坦福监狱实验（Stanford Prison Experiment）和斯坦利·米尔格兰姆（Stanley Milgram）研究等心理学研究的桎梏，以至于我们仍然在服从权威？这项研究已经过去了几十年，但当明知不该这样做时，我们仍然向权威屈服。那么你认为你的书和你的工作会比以往的研究产生更深远的影响吗？
deeply than that? Well, I certainly hope so. I mean, that's the idea, right, is to make defiance accessible to everyone. And Stanley Milgram's work was definitely an inspiration when I looked at the amount of obedience that we have. But what really fascinated me with that work was the defiant subjects. What enabled them to defy? And that is what I do a really deep dive on. It's the kind of book I wish I had had growing up, a step-by-step strategy to learn the will and the skill to defy. how can we do this and how can we practice this. So I want to make defiance accessible to everyone because with defiance, we often think that it is loud or aggressive or violent. And it's none of those things. It's simply living in an alignment with our values. And it's accessible to everyone.
嗯，我当然希望如此。我的意思是，这就是初衷，对吧？就是让每个人都能做到反叛。当我看到我们顺从的程度时，斯坦利·米尔格兰姆的工作绝对给了我启发。但这项工作真正让我着迷的是那些反叛的受试者。是什么让他们能够反叛？这正是我进行深入剖析的内容。这就是我希望自己成长过程中能读到的那种书，一本循序渐进的策略指南，教你学会反叛的意志和技能，教我们如何做到这一点以及如何进行练习。所以我希望让每个人都能实现反叛，因为谈到反叛时，我们通常认为它是喧闹的、具侵略性的或是暴力的。而它绝不是这些。它仅仅是按照我们的价值观生活。并且每个人都可以做到。
It's not a personality. It's a practice. And that's a key point of misunderstanding what it means to defy is that we think we don't have the personality for it. You don't need to have a large than life personality. We can all defy in ways that are unique to us and with far less angst than we had in the past. So it's just learning how to do that. So what are some good ways of saying no without offending another person or completely blowing up the situation? So there's five stages of defiance that I've discovered. And the first one is tension. And we can see that in the Milgram experiments, the obedience to authority experiments, where the experimenter is asking a participant to give what they believe is harmful electric shocks to another person.
它不是一种人格特质。而是一种练习。这是对反叛含义产生误解的一个关键点，我们认为自己不具备那种人格。你不需要拥有那种光芒四射、超越常人的人格。我们都可以以对自己独特的方式进行反叛，并且比过去少得多的焦虑感。所以这只是学习如何做到这一点的问题。那么，在不冒犯他人或彻底搞砸局面的情况下，说“不”的好方法有哪些呢？我发现了反叛的五个阶段。第一个阶段是紧张（tension）。我们可以在米尔格兰姆实验、服从权威实验中看到这一点，实验人员要求参与者对另一个人施加他们认为是伤害性的电击。
You can see some of the subjects showing signs of tension, sort of nervous laughter, hesitating, and those moments are really important to acknowledge, because often when we feel uncomfortable in a situation, we have a sign of tension that we know. This is what always happens me. Either you feel something in your stomach, you feel queasy, or your throat goes dry. It's different for every person. It manifests in different ways, but we have to get in touch with what is the tension that we have. Now, the second stage is really acknowledging that tension to ourselves, because often we just disregard it. We think it's not worth our doubt. We think the other person knows better, or nobody else is saying anything, and it's going to be fine. And so we push it away. And that's really
你可以看到一些受试者表现出紧张的迹象，比如紧张的笑声、犹豫不决，而这些时刻非常重要，需要去承认，因为通常当我们在某种情境中感到不舒服时，我们会表现出自己所熟知的紧张信号。这总是发生在我们身上。要么你感到胃里不舒服，感到恶心，要么你的喉咙变干。每个人的表现都不同。它以不同的方式显现，但我们必须弄清楚我们所感受到的紧张是什么。现在，第二阶段是真正向我们自己承认这种紧张，因为通常我们只是忽视它。我们认为它不值得我们怀疑。我们认为另别人懂的更多，或者没有人在说什么，事情会没问题的。于是我们把它推开。这真的是
a shame because we're ignoring a really fundamental warning system that could be really powerful to us that we might need to defy. Now, coming to your question of how can we do this without offending the other person? This is stage three of defiance and it's actually a critical stage because if we can get to stage three, the research shows you're more likely to get to the final stage five and the act of defiance. So in this stage three, it's simply vocalizing your discomfort to someone else. And it's just saying, I'm not comfortable with that or asking for clarification. What do you mean by that? Have you considered this? And in this stage, you are still in a subservient position. You're just asking for clarification. Like, what is it that's really going on in this
一件令人遗憾的事，因为我们忽略了一个真正基础的警告系统，它对我们可能非常强大，我们可能需要用它来反叛。现在，回到你的问题：我们如何在不冒犯对方的情况下做到这一点？这是反叛的第三阶段，它实际上是一个至关重要的阶段。研究表明，如果我们能够到达第三阶段，你就更有可能到达最后的第五阶段并采取反叛行动。因此在第三阶段，它仅仅是向其他人表达你的不适。只需说：“我对此感到不舒服”，或者请求澄清：“你这话是什么意思？你考虑过这个吗？”在这个阶段，你仍然处于顺从的地位。你只是在请求澄清。比如，在这个
situation. And so I call it curiosity, not confrontation. So let's ask some questions and find out what's going on because, again, a myth of defiance is that it's emotional and loud and aggressive. And that's not what defiance is. It's simply acting in alignment with your values and knowing what's going on. So it's not about confrontation. It's about living your life in alignment with integrity. Do you think girls are still socialized to be more compliant than boys? In your research, are you seeing gender differences in how likely men and women are to be defiant? So I've run quite a lot of studies on whether people will comply with bad advice. And in most of them, there were no gender differences.
情境中到底发生了什么？所以我称之为“好奇，而非对抗”（curiosity, not confrontation）。所以让我们提出一些问题，弄清楚到底发生了什么，因为再次强调，关于反叛的一个神话是它是情绪化的、喧闹的且具有侵略性的。而反叛绝非如此。它仅仅是按照你的价值观行事，并了解正在发生的事情。所以这不是关于对抗。这是关于带着正直过你的生活。你认为女孩们受到的社会化教育仍然比男孩更顺从吗？在你的研究中，你是否看到男女在反叛可能性上的性别差异？我做过相当多关于人们是否会顺从糟糕建议的研究。在大多数研究中，没有发现性别差异。
Milgram found the same in his studies that the obedience to authority was the same for women as it was for men. So in that aspect, I haven't seen gender differences. It affects us all, this reluctance to defy affects us all. There was one study, however, I did see a gender difference. And that is in what I call the ferry study, where we approached over 250 passengers going from Long Island to Connecticut. And we had a middle-aged white man sort of dressed quite smartly, approached passengers as if he was an employee, of the ferry to ask them to fill out a short survey. And the short survey were quite innocuous questions, such as is the fairy clean, was it leaving on time, was very short. And he promised them $5 if they finished the survey. So after they finished the survey, he then asked them, well, I could give you the $5 as promised, or I could enter you into this mystery lottery that pays out between $0 and $10,
米尔格兰姆在他的研究中也发现了同样的结果，即女性对权威的服从与男性相同。所以在这一方面，我没有看到性别差异。这影响着所有人，这种不愿反叛的倾向影响着所有人。然而，有一项研究中我确实看到了性别差异。那是在我称之为“渡轮研究”（ferry study）的研究中，我们走近了从长岛（Long Island）开往康涅狄格州（Connecticut）的 250 多名乘客。我们让一个穿着相当讲究的中年白人男子，像渡轮员工一样接近乘客，请他们填写一份简短的调查问卷。这份简短的问卷是一些相当无害的问题，比如渡轮干净吗？它准时出发吗？非常简短。他向他们承诺，如果完成问卷就给他们 5 美元。在他们完成问卷后，他接着问他们：嗯，我可以如约给你们 5 美元，或者我可以把你们拉进一个神秘的彩票抽奖中，奖金在 0 到 10 美元之间，
but the average payment is less than $5. So once he said that, there was different conditions. With that alone and no advice about what to do, most of the people chose the $5 cash. Just give me $5, right? Why would I enter a lottery where the expected value is less than $5? And so it was 92% of people chose the cash, showing by far this is the preferred option.
但平均奖金低于 5 美元。一旦他这么说，就出现了不同的条件。仅仅这样说，且没有任何关于该怎么做的建议时，大多数人都选择了 5 美元现金。就给我 5 美元好了，对吧？为什么我要参加一个期望值低于 5 美元的彩票呢？因此有 92% 的人选择了现金，这清楚地表明这是首选方案。
In another condition, as well as presenting the two, options, he also said, advised them to take the lottery, just recommended it. I think you should go for the lottery. Here now, people took it. 20% now took the lottery or just over. And then when he disclosed an ulterior motive that he would also receive a bonus if they took the lottery, it more than doubled to 42%. And when I asked the passengers afterwards, why? It's, it's It wasn't because they liked the advisor more. In fact, they liked him less once the disclosure was there. They felt much more uncomfortable to turn down the recommendation with disclosure than without,
在另一种条件下，除了提出这两种选择之外，他还建议他们参加彩票，直接推荐了它。我想你应该去买彩票。现在，人们接受了。略多于 20% 的人现在接受了彩票。接着，当他披露了一个隐藏的动机——如果他们参加彩票，他也会获得一笔奖金时——这一比例增加了一倍多，达到了 42%。事后我问乘客为什么？这不是因为他们更喜欢这位顾问。事实上，一旦披露了信息，他们反而更不喜欢他了。有披露时拒绝推荐，比没有披露时让他们感到更不舒服，
much like I did with Dan, the financial advisor. Here, we saw a gender difference. We weren't expecting one, but when we measured insinuation anxiety, it was far higher in the women than it was in the men. And that could be because it was a man given the advice or the men didn't expect this man to be given them benevolent advice in any way or they felt more comfortable to reject the advice. But that experiment showed me there are situations where insinuation is more powerful for some people than it is for others. And we need to be aware of that. What about cultural differences?
就像我对财务顾问丹做的那样。在这里，我们看到了性别差异。我们并没有预料到会有这种差异，但当我们测量暗示焦虑时，女性的暗示焦虑远高于男性。这可能是因为给出建议的是个男人，或者男性根本不指望这个男人会以任何方式给他们提供仁慈的建议，或者他们觉得拒绝这个建议更自在。但那个实验向我表明，在某些情况下，暗示对某些人的作用比对其他人更强大。我们需要意识到这一点。文化差异又如何呢？
In the U.S., we think of ourselves as a nation of individualists. And is that self-image correct? Or are we just as likely to comply as people in other countries? I mean, the Milgram experiment was conducted, so 35 years after Milgram conducted in then early 1960s. And what people found was that obedience hadn't changed over that time, even though they were actually increased perceptions of agency and autonomy. So we do think of ourselves as possessing agency.
在美国，我们将自己视为一个个人主义国家。这种自我形象正确吗？还是我们和其他国家的人一样容易顺从？我的意思是，米尔格兰姆实验是在他进行实验大约 35 年后的 20世纪 60 年代初进行的。人们发现，在这期间，服从度并没有改变，尽管实际上人们对代理权（agency）和自主性的感知增强了。所以我们确实认为自己拥有代理权。
And yet, with my experiments, I see an extremely high rate of compliance. So in some of the lottery experiments that I'm describing to you, I see rates of compliance of 85% or over. And this is what researchers call a ceiling effect, and that is very hard to get higher compliance. So when I get asked, like, do you think we'll see different results in different countries? well, if we're getting such high compliance in the U.S., then I'm not sure that we're going to sort of see higher compliance elsewhere. And so I really do think we in America think that we are more defiant than we actually are and that we have possessed more agency than we actually display.
然而，在我的实验中，我看到了极高的顺从率。因此，在我向你描述的一些彩票实验中，我看到顺从率高达 85% 甚至更高。这就是研究人员所说的“天花板效应”（ceiling effect），要获得更高的顺从度非常困难。因此，当有人问我：你认为我们在不同国家的实验中会看到不同的结果吗？嗯，如果我们能在美国得到如此高的顺从度，那么我不敢确定我们在其他地方会看到更高的顺从度。因此，我确实认为我们美国人认为自己比实际表现得更具反叛精神，我们拥有的自主性也比实际展现出来的更多。
Now, sometimes it's dangerous to be defiant, whether that's for your career or health or mental health or for a physical safety. So how can people decide when is the right time to comply and when it's really necessary to defy? Great question. So defiance is never completely risk-free. And there are costs to defiance. Like the things that we worry about that is going to cost me a relationship. It might cost me a job. It might be actually physically dangerous at points. But what we often forget is that there's costs to being compliant and giving up our agency. So bowing our head to others continuously and disregarding our values. So I recommend assessing the situation for defiance in two ways.
有时候，反叛是危险的，无论是对你的职业、健康、心理健康还是人身安全而言。那么人们如何决定什么时候是顺从的正确时机，什么时候又真的有必要反叛呢？好问题。因此，反叛永远不可能是完全无风险的。反叛是有代价的。就像我们担心的那些事情一样，它可能会让我失去一段关系。它可能会让我失去一份工作。在某些时刻，它甚至可能在身体上是危险的。但我们经常忘记的是，顺从和放弃我们的自主性也是有代价的。也就是不断地向他人低头并忽视我们的价值观。因此，我建议通过两种方式来评估是否需要反叛的情境。
So two key questions that we want to ask. And the first one is, is it safe? So of course physically, but also maybe financially, psychologically, emotionally, we want to ask ourselves those questions. again, it can never be completely safe. So the question is really, is it safe enough? Is it safe enough? And then the second question is, is it effective? Will it be effective? Will I have some positive impact? And again, effective enough. Because some people don't really think about the positive impact because it's more important for them to take a stand for what they believe in, regardless of whether it has a positive impact or not. And so if we think, Think about like some of the really famous acts of defiance in history, like Rosa Parks. I mean, she was not safe to defy. She was living under segregation, under mortal threat at times.
也就是我们要问的两个关键问题。第一个是：它是安全的吗？当然是从身体上来说，但也可能在财务上、心理上、情感上，我们要问自己这些问题。再说一次，它永远不可能完全安全。所以真正的问题是：它够安全吗？它是否足够安全？然后第二个问题是：它有效吗？它会有效吗？我会产生一些积极的影响吗？同样，必须是足够有效。因为有些人并不真正考虑积极影响，因为对他们来说，为自己信仰的事情立场坚定更为重要，而不管它是否产生积极影响。因此，如果我们想想历史上一些真正著名的反叛行为，比如罗莎·帕克斯（Rosa Parks）。我的意思是，她反叛并不安全。她生活在种族隔离制度下，有时面临着致命的威胁。
There was many consequences as well for her defiance that people don't talk about. It really had a huge impact on her. She lost her job. She was unemployed for 10 years. There were many consequences. But when she was asked 10 years later, would she do it again? She was a course, you know, and she had actually practiced for that moment. It wasn't a spontaneous decision like some people think.
人们没有谈论的，还有她的反叛带来的许多后果。它确实对她的生活产生了巨大的影响。她失去了工作。她失业了 10 年。有许多后果。但当她在 10 年后被问及她是否会再做一次时，她当然回答会，你知道的，她实际上为那一刻进行了练习。这并不像某些人想象的那样是一个冲动的决定。
She had been practicing for that moment in years. And at that particular point, her defiance calculus, whether it was safe or effective enough, was a yes for her. Now, here's a question for parents and other caregivers. You don't want your toddler to be defiant every time you need to get them in their car seat. So how do you teach children to respect adults and other children, but also to stand up to themselves when necessary? Well, one of the things that I think we do for most children is train them in compliance. We train them in compliance a lot. And if we misunderstand what defiance actually means, which is acting in alignment with your values, some of them, especially when it comes to teens, and they're doing the exact opposite of what you tell them. No, I have a teenager right now.
她为那一刻练习了好几年。而在那个特定的时刻，她关于反叛的计算——它是否安全或足够有效——对她来说是一个肯定的答案。现在，这里有一个针对父母和其他照顾者的问题。你并不希望你的幼儿在你每次需要把他们放进安全座椅时都表现得叛逆。那么，你如何教导孩子尊重成年人和其他孩子，但在必要时也能挺身而出维护自己呢？嗯，我认为我们对大多数孩子做的事情之一，就是对他们进行顺从训练。我们对他们进行了大量的顺从训练。如果我们误解了反叛的真正含义，即按照你的价值观行事，他们中的一些人，特别是涉及到青少年时，就会做完全与你告诉他们相反的事情。不，我现在就有一个青少年。
So some of these scenarios are very vivid in my mind, such as playing the Xbox, for example, and I would love him to do his homework instead. And so I ask him, are you going to do your homework? Well, and he's like, well, I was going to do my homework. But now that you've asked me to, I'm not going to do it. And so what does that show us? Is that being defiant? Well, actually, in my definition, no.
所以其中一些场景在我的脑海中非常生动，比如玩 Xbox，而我更希望他去做作业。所以我问他：你打算做作业吗？嗯，他会说：嗯，我本来打算做作业的。但既然你要求我做了，我就不做了。那么这向我们展示了什么？这叫反叛吗？事实上，根据我的定义，不是。
because what he's doing is listening intently to what I'm saying and acting in the exact opposite direction, which means that it's what I call false defiance. But defiance like consent comes from within. It's not from an external source. It doesn't depend on anybody else's expectations. It's coming from within you. And so that's not really defiance. And what we need to do is actually train our children to,
因为他所做的是认真听取我说的话，并朝着完全相反的方向采取行动，这意味着我称之为“虚假反叛”（false defiance）。但反叛就像同意一样，是发自内心的。它不是来自外部源头。它不依赖于任何其他人的期望。它是从你内心深处发出的。所以这并不真的是反叛。我们需要做的是真正训练我们的孩子们去，
be defined. If we think of defiance as a good, positive force, we want to give them training in that. So one of the ways this really hit home was when I was about six or seven years old and I was walking home with my mom from the grocery store. And my mom was wheeling the shopping cart, which was just like an old rickety cart on two wheels, a bit like wheel luggage that we take to the airports. And it had our produce in it. And it was quite a long walk back home. I grew up in Yorkshire in England, and we wanted to take a shortcut through what we call there a snicket. A snicket is just a very narrow alleyway, and we decided to go through that alleyway on the way home to reduce the length of our walk. Now, in that alleyway, we were confronted with about five or six teenage boys,
学会反叛。如果我们认为反叛是一种好的、积极的力量，我们希望在这方面对他们进行训练。这种感悟真正深入我心的情境之一，是我大约六七岁的时候，我和妈妈从杂货店步行回家。我妈妈推着购物车，那只是一辆装在两个轮子上的旧破车，有点像我们带到机场的带轮行李。里面装着我们的农产品。走回家是一段相当长的路。我在英格兰约克郡（Yorkshire）长大，我们想抄近路穿过我们在那里称为 snicket 的地方。snicket 只是一条非常狭窄的小巷，我们决定在回家的路上穿过那条小巷，以缩短步行距离。然而在那条小巷里，我们遇到了大约五六个十几岁的男孩，
and they blocked our path, and they shouted out some obnoxious things to us and told us to go back Now, my mom is quite petite. She's 4'10 at the most. She was wearing her blue sari. She had her hair neatly platted back one single plat. And the way I thought about my mom, if we think about compliance and defiance as binary, which I've realized it is not, you know, there's these stages of defiance. But if we do think about it that way, I had very neatly put her in the compliant box because she served everybody's needs. She did the cooking, the cleaning, the grocery shopping. She was always looking after other people. She was not loud or aggressive. And until that day, I thought she was completely compliant. But when this happened and those boys stopped her, my reaction to them was instant. So I grabbed my mom's arm and I averted my gaze. I did not want to look at them.
他们挡住我们的去路，对我们大喊大叫一些令人讨厌的话，叫我们滚回去。现在，我妈妈个子很小。她最多四英尺十英寸（约 147 厘米）。她穿着蓝色的纱丽（sari）。她的头发整齐地编在脑后，梳成一条辫子。在我对妈妈的印象中，如果我们把顺从和反叛视为二进制的——我意识到它并不是，你知道的，反叛有这些不同的阶段——但如果我们确实那样看待它，我曾非常整齐地把她归入“顺从”的盒子里面，因为她满足了所有人的需求。她做饭、打扫卫生、买杂货。她总是照顾别人。她既不喧闹也不具侵略性。直到那天以前，我都认为她是完全顺从的。但当这件事发生、那些男孩拦住她时，我对他们的反应是本能的。所以我抓住了妈妈的胳膊，移开了视线。我不想看着他们。
And I just wanted to maneuver as fast as possible through them to go home. and she stopped and she looked at them straight in the eye and she said, What do you mean? And my heart started racing. I grabbed her arm even tighter and I whispered to her, no, come on, Ma. And she shrugged me off. She said no.
我只想以最快的速度从他们中间穿过去回家。而她停了下来，直视着他们的眼睛说：“你们什么意思？”我的心开始狂跳。我把她的胳膊抓得更紧了，对她低声说：“不，走吧，妈妈。”她甩开我的手臂。她说：“不。”
And then she got the shopping cart. She put it up upright and she put one hand on her hip. And she looked back at the boys again and she said, What do you mean? And the boys didn't say anything. They were looking at each other. And she said, oh, yeah, you think you're so big and strong, big tough boys, right? Clever boys.
然后她拿了购物车。她把它扶正，一只手叉在腰上。她又回头看了看那几个男孩，说：“你们什么意思？”男孩们什么也没说。他们互相看着。她说：“哦，是啊，你们觉得自己又大又强壮，了不起的硬汉对吧？聪明的男孩。”
And again, there was complete silence from their side. And then one of the boys looked at the other and said, let's go. And they just dispersed. And I was astounded because I never expected that from my mom that day. And she grabbed the shopping cart and then she started walking back home really fast. and I kind of stood frozen for a while before I ran after her. But what that really showed me was a couple of things. One is that defiance is not a personality, it's a practice.
对方依然是一片沉默。接着，其中一个男孩看着另一个说：“我们走吧。”然后他们就散开了。我感到很震惊，因为那天我从我妈妈身上完全没料到这一点。她抓起购物车，然后开始飞快地走回家里。我在她后面追上去之前，在原地呆住了一会儿。但这件事真正向我展示了几点。第一，叛逆不是一种性格，而是一种实践。
It's a skill set that we can choose to use or not. And it became clear to me that she had encountered those boys before, but that day she did something different. She must have been practicing for it, or perhaps I was there in that moment, and she wanted to show me something. And that day she did something different. So even if we're being conditioned to comply the way I was, that I'm sure the way that my mother was as well,
它是一套我们可以选择使用或不使用的技能。我很清楚，她以前遇到过那些男孩，但那天她做了一些不同的事情。她一定一直在为此练习，或者也许我当时就在场，她想向我展示点什么。那天她做了一些不同的事情。所以，即使我们被训练去顺从——就像我一样，我相信我母亲过去也是这样——
compliance might be our default, but it's not our destiny. The second thing that it showed me is that defiance might change you. The instances where I've been able to defy, it is transformational. We feel more authentic, more honest. It's more joyful life to be able to live in alignment with your values. but it also changes the people that observe it. I mean, my mom's defiance definitely had an impact on me. It stayed with me.
顺从可能是我们的默认状态，但它并不是我们的宿命。它向我展示的第二件事是，叛逆可能会改变你。我能够进行叛逆的那些时刻具有变革性的意义。我们会感到更加真实、更加诚实。能够按照自己的价值观生活，是更加快乐的人生。但它也会改变那些观察它的人。我是说，我妈妈的叛逆绝对对我有影响。它留在了我心中。
And it's what I call this ripple effect or the defiance domino effect is that it inspires other people to also go along with their values instead of going along with other people. And that's why it's really important because if we want to train our children to be defiant, these moments are what creates society. And what I really hope for with my book and making to find successful and a changing our understanding is that one day, one of those teens would have spoken up and said, stop doing that to his friends. So my immigrant mother wouldn't have to. So just to close, let me ask you, what are the big questions you still want to answer? What's next for you in research? Well, I am researching what I call the voice empathy gap. So I've interviewed over 50 nurses and nurse managers.
这就是我所说的涟漪效应或叛逆多米诺骨牌效应，它激励其他人也去坚持自己的价值观，而不是随波逐流。这就是它非常重要的地方，因为如果我们想训练我们的孩子敢于叛逆，这些时刻就是塑造社会的原因。我对我这本书的真正期望，以及让反抗变得成功并改变我们的理解，是希望有一天，其中一个青少年会站出来对他的朋友说：“别那样做。”这样我的移民母亲就不用出头了。所以最后，请允许我问你，你仍然想解答的重大问题是什么？你在研究方面的下一步计划是什么？嗯，我正在研究我所说的心声同理心鸿沟。所以，我已经采访了50多名护士和护士长。
And what I've uncovered is that when you ask nurses why they don't speak up in a situation at work, when they see some errors, the reasons that they give are very different from why their nurse managers think that they don't speak up. So there is this gap in how it's viewed in that the nurses don't think it's safe or effective enough. And the nurse managers think it's to do with the characteristics of the nurses, is that they're not taking responsibility for things that go wrong or that they just don't have the ability or the skill set or the confidence to speak up. Looking into interventions to decrease that gap,
我发现的是，当你问护士为什么在工作看到一些错误时不在场开口反映，他们给出的原因与他们的护士长认为他们不开口反映的原因有很大不同。因此，在如何看待这一问题上存在这种鸿沟，护士们认为这不够安全或不够有效。而护士长则认为这与护士的性格有关，是她们没有为出错的事情承担责任，或者她们根本没有开口说话的能力、技能或自信。我正在研究缩小这一鸿沟的干预措施，
because if we have a different understanding about what's causing people to speak up, then we have some kind of status quo where the environment and the culture doesn't change. And that's really important for us to manage if we want to create the right types of culture for people to speak up. Well, Dr. Saw, I want to thank you for joining me today.
因为如果我们对导致人们开口说话的原因有不同的理解，那么我们就会陷入某种环境和文化不会改变的现状。如果我们想为人们敢于直言创造正确的文化类型，管理这一点非常重要。索博士，我想感谢你今天能参加我的节目。
This has been really interesting. Thank you so much. I really enjoyed the conversation. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology. Or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. For those of you who want to know more about psychology and the work of APA, you can join us as a supporter.
这真的非常有趣。非常感谢你。我很享受这次对话。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology 上找到《心理学谈话》之前的节目。或者在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您收听播客的地方。如果您喜欢我们节目的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评价。对于那些想要了解更多关于心理学和美国心理协会工作的人，您可以作为支持者加入我们。
have to be a psychologist. The benefits include a subscription to our award-winning magazine monitor on psychology, as well as discounts on our books and other publication. So if psychology is your passion, or if you just want to know more about the science, you can become a supporter by visiting at.a.a.org slash speaking. That's att.a.a.org slash speaking. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts. You can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up
不必非得是心理学家。福利包括订阅我们屡获殊荣的杂志《心理学观察》，以及购买我们书籍和其他出版物的折扣。因此，如果心理学是您的热情所在，或者您只是想了解更多关于这门科学的知识，您可以访问 att.a.a.org slash speaking 来成为支持者。网址是 att.a.a.org slash speaking。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法。您可以给我们发送电子邮件，邮箱是 speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·维内曼制作。感谢您收听美国心理协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。放松身心，让拉尔夫超市配送本周为您代劳杂货采购。我们只挑选最新鲜的商品，然后检查您的购物清单并仔细挑选每一件。接着我们会把它们全部打包好
and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes, so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并在短短30分钟内送达，让您确信这就是您所订购的商品。新鲜杂货，随您心意，尽在拉尔夫超市配送与自提服务。现在，您的第一笔配送或自提订单还可以节省20美元。拉尔夫超市，为每个人带来新鲜。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。